raf mohamed n'a que 18 ans mais une
volonté de fer samedi elle foulait le
sol canadien après une semaine de cavale
qui l'a amenée du koweit à la thaïlande
une histoire qui a fait le tour du monde
elle demandait l'asile voulait s'enfuir
en australie mais c'est le canada qui a
répondu en premier sur l'insistance du
haut commissariat aux réfugiés
elle raconte qu'elle pensait s'en fuir
depuis l'âge de 16 ans raf ne pouvait
plus supporter le sort réservé aux
femmes dans son pays
elles sont traités en esclaves
on ne peut rien dire rien faire on m'a
même enfermée pendant six mois parce que
je m'étais coupé les cheveux
elle rappelle que les femmes en arabie
saoudite ont un statut de mineur raf
était constamment surveillé par son père
et son frère
elle a donc attendu d'atteindre sa
majorité à 18 ans pour s'enfuir
j'avais peur mais j'étais prête à tout
risquer pour ma liberté
c'est lors d'un voyage au koweit avec
ses parents qu'elle fuit en pleine nuit
une fois mes parents dormi j'ai tout
organiser
j'ai quitté pour la thaïlande à cette
heure le matin en arrivant ici
arrivée à bangkok on lui confisque son
passeport elle se barricade dans une
chambre d'hôtel et demande l'asile
ma vie était en danger
je n'avais rien à perdre téléphone
cellulaire en main elle créé un compte
twitter
raf veut alerter le monde sur sa
condition j'étais prête à mettre fin à
ma vie
informé le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés intervient c'est le canada qui
l'accueillera entre temps ses parents
ont répudié et là le vernis craque elle
doit quitter l'entretien pour se
ressaisir
elle ne veut plus utiliser son nom de
famille et rejette la religion musulmane
raf affirme qu'elle reçoit une centaine
de messages de haine par jour sur son
téléphone souhaite tels que d'autres
femmes saoudiennes suivent son exemple
j'espère que les lois vont changer dans
mon pays c'est un gros risque de
s'enfuir mais si ça ne change pas fuyez
à partir de maintenant elle veut
apprendre l'anglais faire des études
pour devenir ingénieur vivre des
aventures découvrir la vie generali
baisse à la fin c'est moi qui vais vivre
ici catherine kovacs radio canada
montréal